the show was originally helmed by  British writers yes Armando Iannucci  created it a genius guy from the UK and  now the show is led by an American team  yes  fundamentally we do we do have a couple  British writers still on board but Dave  Mandel is now our executive until very  talented guy yes he speaks highly of you  incidentally no yes I asked him to have  you noticed since it's changing since  it's changed now and it's maybe skewing  a little more American than Bruce Wayne  so have you noticed a change at all in  the writing or the style of the writing  or the styles of curse words well we  used to say a lot now we say we want to  but our president to put an end to that  so none of this answer will be on  television no guess what it's all going  to be on television and the kids on  Nickelodeon are going to learn a lot for  asking  you